Married women were originally banned from
watching the Olympic Games in ancient Greece.
If they did, they were promptly thrown off
a cliff.
Welcome to RIF
For decades the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration have been tracking a single
mysterious whale that speaks its own language.
It sings at a frequency that no other whale
transmits at.
It has been called "the world's loneliest
whale".
In South Korea two barber's poles next to
each spinning in opposite directions are used
to signify a brothel.
The anti-piracy group BREIN, who are responsible
for putting the anti-piracy ad on all your
DVDs was sued for stealing the theme song.
During World War 2, a U.S. soldier named Dirk
J. Vlug was ambushed by 5 Japanese tanks.
He single-handedly destroyed all 5 and was
eventually awarded the Medal of Honour.
In the Dark ages up to the 1800s animals were
sentenced for human crimes.
Dogs, pigs, cows, rats and even flies and
caterpillars were prosecuted in court on charges
ranging from murder to obscenity.
At birth, babies don't have kneecaps.
Kneecaps do not develop completely until after
six months.
After a male penguin falls in love, he will
search the entire beach to find the perfect
pebble to give to her.
The average American eats an amount of fat
equivalent to one whole stick of butter each
day.
For every human killed by a shark, humans
kill two million sharks.
And finally if a person yelled for 8 years,
7 months, and 6 days, he or she would produce
enough energy to heat just one cup of coffee.